how about that shot 51 minutes the
official length of the rain delay
40 degrees at first pitch
herman marcus who's a native of
venezuela
comes flying out to the mound ready for
round two
switch hitting katel marte at the plate
martay swung out and missed
so 97 on by can tell martay
truck starting pitcher for the d-backs
it's luke weaver pitches from last year
show a good fastball change up combo
this year he's expanded that cutter into
a slider that's the big change for this
year hey it's great to see
rob mel tapia back in the lineup he
started the first three ball games then
crashed into the wall
and did pinch hit on sunday
center field that will drop and a
leadoff single for rymel
so he continues his hot hand against the
diamondbacks
two outs now and blackman will take his
turn
hard on the ground but right at
christian walker
well the rocky's got a base hit from
topi and then three hard hit balls but
nothing to show for it
we'll go to the second no score ryan
mcmahon left-handed hitting
third baseman and he drives his ball
high and deep right center field
take a good look you won't see it for
long
one-nothing colorado well if you're
going to swing
3-0 you might as well do some damage you
better get
the barrel out mac did
the distance of 415 feet love it i love
the 3-0 swing
when you do it like that so does your
manager and your teammates
second home run of the year for mac
fourth rbi
[Applause]
[Music]
just a deep right stay up and get out it
does
right over the scoreboard two nothing
colorado
nudia is his second of the year in that
dodger series there were six home runs
hit by the rockies
by six different guys but dom nunez and
ryan mcmahon were part of that that
group of six
and they're doing it tonight did he just
open those hips up so nicely on the
subaru super bowl we see the grip the
grip obviously works
and he takes it yard in a hurry
two outs for ryan mcmahon homer to right
back in the second one of two solo shots
that inning for the rockies
swing and a high fly ball center field
back goes martay onto the track at the
fence he reaches up and it's off the top
of the fence
and it is a home run
second on the night as it went off the
top and went over
and then ricocheted back into play
ryan mcmahon second home run of the
night and the rockies lead it three to
nothing
martay got back to the fence
and might have gotten a glove on it but
it went
over that yellow pad hit
the either some fencing you hit
fencing and then came back and
the d-backs were playing it like it was
still in play but
second base umpire pat holberg
signaled that it was a home run and the
rockies have a three to nothing lead
cabrera escobar and kelly five six and
seven
the d-backs fifth three-one on cabrera
and there's a leadoff base runner he
goes back into the stretch where he has
struggled with command
checks cabrera that one to the back stop
rolls over toward the first base dugout
cabrera wide turned at second
cabrera the runner at third with two men
out pitched to perdomo
and there's ball four and now weaver
who was a strikeout victim his first
time up
lines it by a diving hamson that'll
bring in a run
and perdomo hustles into third it's an
rbi
single for luke weaver right backs in
the fifth finally got to airman marquez
who gave up two walks and a two out
single by the pitcher luke weaver
for the diamondbacks first run kattel
sends one into center
and that's a lead off single their third
hit kind of start off a good inning here
christian walker now christian needs a
long ball needs a gapper
[Applause]
christian turns on one down the line
christian walker
has tied the ball game
first of the year for walker and it's
3-3
crisp and clean resounding crack of the
bat on the ball
all right henry yenci el monte has come
on from the colorado bullpen this is a
guy that very quietly did a nice job for
bud black last year
they'll face geraldo perdomo steven vogt
and pavon smith eight nine and one
domain lists one out to shallow left
center
and it's in there for head number one
geraldo perdomo welcome to the big
leagues young man there it is
first of many that ball will end up on
his mantle
ahead of stephen vogt
stephen vogt sends one out to right
field
steven vogt say goodbye
five three diamondbacks they
trailed it three nothing they laid it
5-3 the second this year for steven vote
not all home run swings are equal it
looked like steven vote got fooled just
a little bit but ends up
getting the barrel on the ball and
that's all you need to do in this
ballpark square it up
get it in the air and you've got a
chance here comes ryan mcmahon
how about three home runs how do you
like that
three for three three bombs ryan mcmahon
rockies within a run it's an easy game
isn't it one-man wrecking crew tonight
[Applause]
that was loud too i mean just pure
barrel
on the baseball now ryan mcmahon
what a night for ryan he became the
third
rocky or excuse me the 18th rocky to hit
three home runs in one game
a line drive caught by the second
baseman escobar
so now the rockies are down to their
final out
sam hilliard over two and a walk
right side of the infield for the
left-handed batter and
hilliard drives it to right and this
ball game
is tied halfway up
the second deck touch them
all time for sam hilliard
oh my did that ball fly
saw what the other guys had gotten this
pitch was left up and it dipped right
into the wheelhouse of hilliard one out
now go ahead run at third for
as drupal cabrera
that one goes right through crone walker
scores and it's six to five diamondbacks
josh fuentes will bat for the pitcher
pitcher spot leads it off for colorado
pull down the line extra bases diaz will
score easily
heading to second is the pitch hitter
josh fuentes
six six winning rod in scoring position
and the batter will be his drubal
cabrera
[Applause]
cabrera that's fair down the line and
the freight trains on the tracks
looking for an extra run they're going
to stop him at third
cabrera's got the rbi double and the
d-backs have a 7-6 lead
7-6 d-backs bottom of the 12th fuentes
down at third and that infield in as
jack mentioned
pitches lifted in the air right field
moving back le castro fuentes tags here
he comes the throw
comes in fuentes scores garrett hampson
with the sacrifice
fly now stephen vogt
is at the plate swung on
the fly ball to left and that falls in
front of tapia for a base hit
tapia for some reason stopped
and in the score comes escobar to make
it
8-7 now savant peacock got a bad for
himself well dude
he's doing it all together he's going to
get a third inning of work here in his
major league debut and getting in the
bat in the process
sky's one shallow left field story out
tapi on
that ball is a base hit and votes going
to go to third base
and matt peacock's got to hit in his big
league debut
and now the batter will beat cattell
martay now is where you really want the
big hit
[Music]
martay lines went into the gap and
they're off to the races
vote is home peacock coming around
third cattell marte a two-run
double 10-7 diamondbacks